my last question before some current
events is uh let's say that
uh you know libertarian conservative uh
viewpoint in the 90s would you consider
yourself a libertarian a republican how
do you kind of label yourself if you had
to put yourself in a box today and like
did that change over time or has it
always been kind of the same box you
would have put yourself in throughout
your life
yeah i guess when i was in college uh
you sort of figure out where your
political views are and how you would
categorize them and and yeah i would say
i was more on the libertarian end
of the the spectrum you know during like
let's say the reagan era
the um
the the conservative movement was sort
of an uneasy
uh alliance of a few different groups
you had sort of free market types a lot
like milton friedman
uh you had
social conservatives and then you had
sort of anti-communist
uh you know cold warrior types and um
and i guess the group that i
identified myth with the most would have
been more on the free market economic
side but i also agree with kind of the
reaganite approach to peace through
strength but in any event um
and then you know after the cold war
ended i think the political categories
got reshuffled a little bit and um
and so i would say yeah my views today
have have evolved and they're probably a
little bit more in a populist
direction um and we can delve more more
into that
explain a little bit more well
so
um
if you look at what the big political
divide is in america if you actually
poll people about their political views
the number one predictor of where
someone's gonna fall in the political
spectrum is whether they have a college
degree or not interesting and so if you
actually look at the views of people who
are in the professional class i.e people
have a college degree
is radically different than the views by
and large of the working class which is
people with just say a high school
education
and that is the fundamental
division in this country now it's not
universally true there are plenty of
people with a college degree like me who
have more let's say working class views
and then vice versa so but by and large
that's the division and there's a whole
host of issues
where uh the the professional class is
very much out of touch with what the
working class thinks and
the uh the uh political scientist who
actually i think has developed this the
most is a guy named roy tashira
who everyone should really check out his
sub stack if you're interested in this
um but he's been doing work over the
last couple of years sort of documenting
this and showing the polling and so
forth
he remember he is the author back in the
early like 2002 of a book called the
coming or democratic majority maybe
emerging democratic majority
in which he predicted
that demographic trends would result
in the election of democratic presidents
as far as the eye could see
and he was then pretty much considered a
prophet because obama then got elected
in 2008 building the type of coalition
that tashira describes in his book
interesting um
but lately over the last couple of years
and tashira is a democrat wants
democrats to win he's been warning the
party you have gotten way too far left
on sociocultural issues like for example
censorship as one of many
um and the reason is because you stop
being a working-class party you are now
a professional class party you cater to
the views
of uh of professional elites
uh and
but but but but you're speaking to
yourself you're speaking increasingly to
an echo chamber because you are out of
touch with
the rest of the country and so for
example
he very much predicted something like
the election of uh glen younkin in
virginia remember
this is a state that is pretty much a
blue state now virginia
biden won the state by 10 points in 2020
and one year later youngkin wins by two
or three points so 12 13 point swing why
on issues like schools you know crt
uh you know wanting to provide
putting the parents back in charge and
providing kids with a high quality
non-ideological
education you know this is the type of
issue that really
sets off most americans but
uh you know
the elites the professional class is
deeply invested in this idea of crt just
to take like one example where there's
like a very big class divide on that
issue
so tushira has been warning about the
way in which the democratic party he
calls it professional class hegemony has
been co-opted by this professional class
now what's happening in the republican
party is really interesting the
republican party is in the process of
transforming itself into a working-class
party very different than
uh what it historically been
historically republican party was more
like a chamber of commerce type of party
now what you see
uh with this more populist
uh edge to it is it's trying to appeal
to the working class now a lot of people
would say it's fake you know it's not
real
but that's kind of what's in the process
of happening um
now you know my theory about why there
is so much contention and divisiveness
in the country what we all feel the
strife is because
if you look at just numbers
30 something like 37 percent of the
country has a college degree it's
professional class 63 is working class
okay so
the working class has the numbers in a
democracy their views should prevail yes
and yet the elites
run every institution from the prestige
media
to hollywood to wall street to the
fortune 500
to the foundations the non-profits the
think tanks the big you know even the
big funds
obviously those are all run by people
with college degrees and so the
professional class hegemony that tushar
talks about the democratic party also
exists across the board in all these
institutions and so by and large you
have this phenomenon of institutions in
this country being out of step with what
most people believe and trying to push
an agenda on them that the rest of the
country doesn't support that is finally
the divide and the friction in this
country
now
you
i think what i've described is just
objectively the case of what's going on
you could still be a member of the
professional class and still think it's
a good thing
that the fortune 500 is pushing will
capitalism or twitter is pushing for
censorship of ideas they don't like and
so on and they do but i think
fundamentally this is the tension is
that
the leadership of the country not just
the political leadership in washington
but really much more deeply
across the board of all of our
institutions they have views that are
out of step with most of the country and
i think how we resolve that
tension
is the that's the political issue of our
time yeah one of the things that as
you're talking immediately jumps to mind
is uh you've probably seen the the
phrase the meme of uh good times create
uh weak man weak men create bad times
right bad times great uh strongmen and
when i think about this there is this
like bifurcation i think economically as
well where we have a country with 45
percent of americans have no investable
assets inflation obviously right now is
at a 40-year
high um and if you were to talk to that
professional class i think most of the
people would say hey the last 10 15
years have been amazing right pretty
much since the global financial crisis
like everyone's gotten richer and richer
but at the same time what we've actually
seen is that that working class hasn't
kind of been along for that ride in the
same way and really they've actually
gone the opposite direction so you kind
of get this widening divide how much of
the economic situation plays into some
of these thought processes and the
transitions between the way that the uh
political you know kind of parties are
actually transitioning is that a fair
way yeah i think
it plays into it hugely and i think one
of the big issues the last 20 years is
the way that our trade policy basically
hollowed out the industrial base of the
country um you know this is the the
phenomenon of you know we brought china
into the wto and we gave them
you know permanent you know basically
mfn status
and as a result we exported millions and
millions of sort of middle-class uh
working-class jobs where people made
things with their hands as opposed to
knowledge worker type jobs overseas to
china and so forth that created enormous
discontent in the country
and that basically is one of the main
reasons why trump got elected in 2016.
remember the the democrats thought they
had this what they called the blue the
blue wall yeah in the midwest the
industrial midwest the the rust belt
and
fell apart it fell apart trump
absolutely shattered that wall
and one of the main ways he did it was
appealing to the fact that really
bipartisan trade policy last 20 years
destroyed
these factory towns all over the midwest
now i think that
when you lose an election to a total
political novice and outsider who has so
many characteristics that you would
think would be disqualifying that the
elite
would basically start having second
thoughts and asking itself tougher
questions about the way they've been
ruling the country
and yet they haven't i mean the reaction
to 2016 basically was this hysteria that
this tds and again
i'm not like
in saying this trying to advocate for
trump or something i'm just advocating
for when you lose an election
you need to have some sense of
introspection and asking
why that happened and how your policies
might have contributed to it i mean the
other big issue that trump ran on
were all these stupid wars that america
has gotten itself into over the last 20
years and remember this was a critique
as much of the republican party as the
democratic party remember when trump
said no more bushes what he meant was no
more stupid wars in the middle east we
got ourselves into
iraq
afghanistan syria libya we spent over
six trillion dollars on nation building
in the middle east and what do we have
to show for it nothing they just hate us
even more the problem is worse than all
these countries you know um afghanistan
is back in the hands of the taliban
iraq is basically now an iranian proxy
state libya is in chaos and civil war
syria assad's still running it um so all
these efforts were for naught and but i
think they along with our trade policy
created tremendous discontent in the
country imagine if we had spent that six
trillion dollars back here at home
fixing some of the problems you're
talking about maybe we wouldn't be at
each other's throats quite so much as we
are today
so
you had these huge issues um in the
country over which discontent was
bubbling over
and
you know instead of basically holding
itself accountable the elites of the
country and it's really again bipartisan
elites who set these policies for two
decades rather than having any
introspection they would blame they
blamed the election on like russian
disinformation that somehow the russians
caused trump to be elected
you know or somehow the country was shot
through with white supremacy that was
the reason trump got elected they never
were willing to look in the mirror and
understand the real causes and what's
happened since 2016 is that
these mythologies have really only grown
and so
this is now what basically somehow has
morphed into this
this censorship crusade where you know
it started with this
again this idea that somehow the
russians were responsible for trump's
election rather than these deep-seated
issues in the country
and that has now blossomed and grown
into this full-fledged um
this sort of content moderation movement
in which we're going to take down and
censor anything we consider to be
disinformation which is basically
anything that the people the elites
running twitter think is is an idea they
disagree with